[ __ ] ya know I'm not an initiative
snail trail on my know that line let me
smell your pants yeah yo you see that
Tyler Perry [ __ ] series that was like
on HBO or some [ __ ] or et which one is
if there's this clip right show me the
[ __ ] there's this clip of this dude
saying take off your pants
yikes and this dude takes off his pants
and he gets down and he sniffs his dick
pick up a bike Tyler Perry what the [ __ ]
are you writing I'm gonna show you this
[ __ ] and it's real if you write so cool
that's the teaser that's just a cliff
yeah if you type on Twitter Tyler Perry
dick Smith and you'll see this dude come
on take off your pants here takes up his
pants and imprison his dicks out no it's
like in a junkyard a car junkyard and
then God goes down he goes comes up real
close to his face he goes down he goes
swish the dick he goes that's the scene
think he sniffs the big I never said
this deal I gotta say no bro that's why
they haven't seen it yet it's just weird
dude lost his [ __ ] mind man he writes
for the people I'm trying to figure out
whose demographic is Atlanta
Elena's storage bin and Walmart it's
kind of those people if Tyler Perry came
up to you and he goes Khalifa I want to
give you the lead role in my film right
all right it's it's a Christmas special
and it's called Madea Goes to Israel
okay right you're gonna need you to play
an Israeli military guy that checks
people to see if they have bombs by
sniffing dicks and then when you go to
smell but these day
you surprised that she has a dick and
it's mine who take that role the role is
for $20,000 and we're gonna shoot in the
summer in Israel yeah for two months
Madea Goes to Israel would I do it yeah
this
I hear desperate I would a lot of things
that I would do for $20,000 oh [ __ ]
I think about the art the art I find
some more than that yeah I'll do some
scrip analysis on that I'll turn that
[ __ ] up did you see a descriptive
analysis and some layers on it it's full
just like okay well I'm not gonna grab
this dick yeah not gonna grab it Cleve I
need to grab dick was my motivation here
yeah this penis yeah did you see that
was it was it a Monique that had a
problem with Tyler Perry I don't know no
her work I don't know anymore
oh I forgot what I repair it was
definitely Giles Butler it was Lee
Daniels was it so Lee Daniels was the
one that that approached Monique with
the whole it because Lee Daniels did
precious yeah right
precious is all about to call the film
precious purple she would get your hair
is called precious right and so mini
Monique played a very integral role in
the film I never actually got to see
precious yet in it no I haven't seen it
but I'm sure that clearly she runs the
chicken and runs yes okay keep it was
amazing without any context of what that
film is that it's like funniest things
I've ever seen in my life and your life
I was like what the sting even this clip
is really done yes very deep yes based
on so many years to the culture I didn't
feed her child like you need yeah but
the fact that she's still in fried
chicken is hilarious yeah it's pretty
bad that's what that's pretty [ __ ]
terrible
yeah and so I guess Monique was offered
a role on the film right yeah and you
know she was kind of
to her account what she was saying she
was I was taken aback because of Oh like
Lee Daniels wants me to work on this art
piece this is amazing well she got paid
wasn't much money right there wasn't a
back-end about her having to program up
to promote the film but she has like all
these like email receipts or whatever
whatnot but what it kind of boiled down
to us after she kind of played the role
and this is before Oprah heard of the
film or anything else she he kind of put
it into words that either was through an
interview or was an email that Monique's
role was to kind of get eyes on the film
and she fulfilled that role is that oh I
thought it was because you told me that
I was gonna be something special to this
[ __ ] character hmm
right so she you know that's pretty
[ __ ] offensive I'd be [ __ ]
offended by that right because the story
behind the Hollywood of anything that
has to do with Monique is the fact that
she's a very difficult person that
Monique is difficult she's hard to deal
with she's allowed or whatever but
Monique's argument to that is that you
could say whatever you want about me
right I'm loud I'm obnoxious I'm highly
opinionated but one thing you can never
say about me is I'm a [ __ ] liar and I
do not lie and um with the whole the
whole Lee Daniels thing and I think Lee
Daniels is cancelled right now right Lee
Dan's can't do [ __ ] I don't forgot what
he did he might have touched the baby or
something really I don't know I don't
know what it is he might've got me to
tour some [ __ ] but what she was
saying about in his case was you know
she felt kind of used right and that
that was the case and then he was upset
at her because she wouldn't do like
promos and tours which wasn't written in
the contract and saying that she was
difficult and you know this is the story
that this is the rhetoric that happens
around Monique a lot right and then
there was that conversation with Monique
and Steve Harvey if you watch The Steve
Harvey Show in the oh and that show that
they go at it dude and not not added as
is screaming at each other but they're
on two opposite ends mmm so Monique is
talking about a lot of prominent black
people in entertainment lost their way
and they kind of lost their integrity
they say they say she says that it feels
like a lot of black people in
entertainment and I'm paraphrasing right
now are still in that survival mode of
like I should be grateful that anybody
wants to [ __ ] with me anyway it's and
anybody wants to give me a paycheck to
do this role she was for for how long
how long am I supposed to do this how
long am I supposed to feel grateful that
I'm lucky
had this role rather than this is a
world for me and I should get paid what
I deserve
I've been in this industry for a very
long time I know my weight I know my I
know my power so what the [ __ ] right and
the Steve is like that's not how you
play the game because I got children to
feed I got all this other stuff and it
kind of made like uncle Steve Steve
seemed like an Uncle Tom Yeah right it's
like oh you just here chasing ass in
dollars right but I think what Steve was
trying to the [ __ ] was that
oh is that the the battery going out on
the [ __ ] monitor some [ __ ] knows but
either way but Monique was talking about
how you know that's that's not a very
there's no integrity in that right she
goes I'm tired of doing this [ __ ] I'm
tired of having to just chase this
almighty dollar and just kind of bow out
and kind of do what everybody else asked
me to do just because I should be
grateful for these [ __ ] roles and
then you know because she went I guess
that camera is also out too either way
[Laughter]
just gonna be wider here but um what
Monique was saying too with Oprah and
the whole Oprah situation was she got
super upset by opening she got really
teary especially when talking about and
she also wants an apology from Oprah
Winfrey and Whoopi Goldberg yeah and
this was like a couple years ago by the
way because what be said to her behind
doors it's like you know what like
you're worried your stance on the stuff
is that you want to make a stance
because you're worried about the
generations before they come after you
right and you know standing up for them
well here's the thing you she's like
just worry about yourself don't worry
about them worry about yourself and that
broke her heart she goes because oh what
about all these other prominent black
woman before me that came before it
became before us and said I'm just gonna
worry about myself and not worry about
the future where would I be what would I
be where would you be right and you're
somebody that should stand up for more
than just this and you're okay just
looking after your back and saying [ __ ]
you to the rest of the everybody else
and she was my heart was broken she also
mentioned like when she had a
conversation with Oprah and she
confronted Oprah I said like you know
you owe me an apology long story short
about that was that this is this is
Monique telling the story Oprah was
gonna do this whole special about her
fucked-up family situation right she
wasn't have her mom
or whatever and she goes no I don't want
you to do that right but instead of
having her maman and her and her mom on
she just brought her whole family on
there without telling her about it and
so she thought they they had a mutual
respect saying like oh I don't want
anything don't don't put up my family
business out there but then Oprah went
ahead and did it anyways without Moni
being there but she brought her family
on and that caused a lot of drama in her
life and she felt [ __ ] disrespected
and so she confronted Oprah about that
and then basically what she told her so
you owe me an apology and then what
Oprah said was that if you feel like I
did something wrong to you I completely
apologize which is not a [ __ ] apology
of course and she didn't feel right
about that stuff and you know what she's
what mo nique told Oprah was hey like I
remember when I was a young fat black
girl and I looked up to you and I said
and I saw you on TV
and I said there's another fat black
woman people respect and love her I want
to be just like you and I don't a field
trip she went to go see her and then um
you know she was inspired as she told
her told that to her as a young little
girl I think whenever I let's say she
was eight years old and then later on
when she started popping off and became
a famous she talked to her and then
Oprah said something to her that stuck
with her that helped her as she goes the
reason why I like you so much it's
because I see a younger version of
myself in you and it empowered her and
someone she confronted that about that
stuff she goes well what does that say
about you when you did all the stuff so
I remember that time when you told me
that you saw a younger self of you you
and me so I want to make sure that I
keep you in check and let you know that
this is wrong she goes sweetie I say
that to everybody
mmm [ __ ] yeah could you imagine it's
like uh saying I saved that single
phrase to everybody yeah and she was
wrecked you know and so she feels like
she deserves an apology from Tyler Perry
and all this other stuff and I I agree
too you know on the political scale is
it a good move but you know what is what
is Monique have to prove now right
besides you know sending up an example
and showing people stuff she goes I
don't respect these [ __ ] what
they did like I love them they're my
brothers like we're we're cool however
this is how I feel about this situation
so this is a wrong that I feel that you
guys did and I feel like you did I
deserve an apology from the way that you
treated me Holly was [ __ ] crazy man
do you mean it could be friends I think
I'm scared of her you talked me into
believing [ __ ]
I don't believe right but the reason why
I like her is because I think she's very
good at proving her point sometimes I
feel like she says she she understeers
she understands and hears you but she
doesn't you don't just wants to get her
point across but I do agree with her but
what I have been bold enough to do what
she didn't know right because I'm not in
her position but I think she's in a
position where she can't speak up
against it people were upset at her
about her Netflix deal because number
one she felt slighted about it but I
think her point was that why can't I
feel slighted about this money that I
feel that I deserve right the whole I
think
Charlamagne tha God had a whole issue
with it because he says that his - his
argument is that at this point you don't
deserve Dave Chappelle money because you
can't bring in Dave Chappelle numbers
mm-hmm right facts
I think that's [ __ ] facts right it's
hard that is anybody that's just that's
not just Monique right but she goes if
if I walk into this Netflix meeting
right and they say to me hey you're a
legend you're the female Dave Chappelle
you're on that type of status right and
then I come back away and then you go
well we're gonna give you $500,000 when
you offer Dave Chappelle 50 60 million
that's what she said they said they told
her she told they offered to offer was
$500,000 right and she goes well that
doesn't make sense for me
number one is offensive number two I
have to do this stand up and I have to
go on tour I can't use this material
it's it's up on this TV screen so this
has to make I'll make about two three
mil yeah doing my regular stuff but I'm
not gonna be able to form this so I
should at least match that and they're
like well we can't do that it's like
that's highly offensive it's super
offensive yeah I actually agreed with
her I was like that when she said five
hundred thousand I was like five hundred
thousand that's it like his [ __ ]
Monique and she does have a huge fan
base right she's definitely worth more
than five hundred thousand at least a
[ __ ] mil for [ __ ] crying out loud
you need a Chappelle sixty million you
could you could give Monique a million
dollars to me to cover up the suspense
that she would lose from doing that
right and uh it's it's in her right to
feel offended by that you know the whole
boycott thing I'm not too sure if I'm on
that side mm-hmm and then her suing
Netflix I think that's a little weird
yeah right but you got the whole she's
not a monolith that's for sure she's
sure he's a all kinds of